I love my Good Morning America I can't
start the day without it GMA I call it
cuz I'm gonna hurry that's a big hurry
hurry Good Morning America I'll just say
GMA say GMA yeah you know what I say I
say come on
what's your watching du'a it's no time
welcome oz doing something called World
Records week did you know that yeah
every morning someone's trying to break
a new record and the other morning a man
attempted to set a new world record for
longest time spent dangling from a rope
using only his teeth I actually saw this
and I was fascinated you know what he
almost almost made
[Applause]
take care of the choppers and the eggs
make care of you
[Music]
[Applause]
he's fine by the way I got everything
back in irony's he's fine